bonjour faudra raquer à saint clair
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors est ce qu'on sera fixé à
peu près vers 13h30 ce qu'on serait fixé
je pense qu'on va être fixé est ce qu'il
y aura rendu un verdict l'a probablement
pas la question et finalement complexe
je vois mal les juges se prononcent
aujourd'hui
alors concrètement les conseils de
fillon estime que la justice n'a pas été
indépendante et que l'anc est finalement
été à charge alors l'enquêté à charge et
à décharge ainsi un juge d'instruction
qui est censé enquêter des de deux
façons mais la problématique et et et
autres c'est à dire que c'est pas le
travail des magistrats du siège qui sont
mis en
le travail du magistrat du siège qui est
mis en cause c'est celui du parquet
c'est-à-dire le fait que le ministère
public ait subi des pressions et que ces
pressions et conduit on l'a entendu dans
les propos de madame houlette et qu'on
ait conduit à l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire et donc
possiblement à une mise en examen
alors que ce qui était son sentiment
premier c'était d'ouvrir simplement une
enquête préliminaire c'est à dire de
garder le l'anc est de 2,2 sur les faits
qui étaient reprochés à françois fillon
dans le cadre du ministère public donc à
partir de ce moment là il n'y a pas
d'information judiciaire si ça avait été
fait comme ça il n'y a pas non plus de
mise en examen et on sent bien que
politiquement s'il ya pas mise en examen
la crédibilité politique de françois
fillon ne s'effondre pas parce que tout
était basé dans sa communication qui
était il faut le reconnaître
arrogante mais elle était quand même ce
qu'elle était on se rappelle qu'ils
imaginent le général de gaulle mise en
examen et bien il l'a été lui par ce
choix et ce choix semble-t-il résultent
de pressions politiques et aujourd'hui
j'imagine que un grand nombre de
français n'ont pas de mal à imaginer que
le ministre de la justice ou que la
chaîne pénale
à cette époque là et fait pression soit
pour des raisons
strictement politique soit pour des
raisons idéologiques c'est à dire que un
juge ou un ensemble de juges de
procureurs de magistrats est décidé à un
moment que le candidat fillon était le
candidat à battre et qu'il était
nécessaire finalement de de faire les
choses rapidement et on a vu que ça a
été fait très rapidement
et tout ça vient des lianes houlette
l'ancien patron du parquet national
financier qui finalement a fédéré des
révélations juste avant procès et elle
est revenue sur ses propos
ça pose là aussi la question de pression
qu'ils continueraient de s'exercer sur
un magistrat honoraire donc il ya il y à
une fragilisation de l'institution
judiciaire
il ya une surexposition de des juges
dans une affaire qui est quand même
principalement politiques qui a déjà une
mise en cause du statut du pmf on l'a
entendu un chez plusieurs députés se pnf
qui était censé normalement s'occuper
d'affaires complexes d'affaires mettant
en cause la dignité de la république
là on peut pas dire que dans le cas d'
un emploi présumé fictif d'une
assistante parlementaire qui remonte à
plus de quinze ans ça soit quelque chose
qui met en cause la dignité de la de la
république donc manifestement il me
semble que au delà de la sphère
politique qui touche principalement
fille françois fillon et qui a pénalisé
sa candidature à l'élection 2017
il y à toute l'institution judiciaire
qui est fragilisé dans cet épisode alors
au cas où l'ancien premier ministre
voilà sortir et blanchi de cette
histoire de cette affaire à ce que vous
imaginez un retour en politique de
françois fillon
non non non il y à certaines personnes
qui effectivement on l'a vu un certains
hommes politiques qui ont du mal à
tourner la page et qui s'en vont mais
qui ne s'en vont pas il y en a d'autres
qui tourne la page qui ne reviennent pas
on allait
en plat gauche de lionel jospin il
semble que françois fillon prennent
cette voie là vous avez aussi l'exemple
de dominique de villepin avec lequel
j'ai j'ai collaboré donc voilà il ya des
personnes qui ont un moment servi l'état
et qui a une pour une raison ou une
autre décide de changer de vie alors ils
servent toujours leur pays mais d'une
façon différente et il semblerait que
françois fillon s'inscrivent plutôt dans
cette ligne là merci frédéric à 5 les
remercie d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes